peu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis jeune lieberman j'ai 85 ans je
suis ceinture noire de judo ceinture
noire d'aïkido et saint-alban de kung fu
et je suis également professeur de yoga
depuis quand pratiquez-vous le judo je
vais 63 ans et j'ai eu ma ceinture noire
à 68 ans puisqu'il faut cinq ans
d'études avant d'être ceinture noire
tout de suite après je suis parti au
japon j'ai eu envie de connaître les
mettre là bas de les contacter et j'ai
toujours extrêmement intéressant et en
effet j'ai eu beaucoup de chance
toujours très très bien sûr les
amicalement su monte à paris et je le
répète beaucoup de choses et j'en ai
fait mon beauf et maintenant je pu les
transmettre à mes élèves et surtout de
la vigueur les cours commencent d'abord
par un cours de gymnastique pour se
mettre en train est ensuite je leur
enseigne la self défense
la self défense ont des mouvements que
j'ai pris et j'ai puisé un peu dans le
confondent dans le judo est dans
l'attitude on y pense parce que je les
personnes très âgées là j'ai 66 ans et
demi j'ai 71 membres les 72 heures qui
75 vous pensez que la self défense ça
peut être utile à des personnes âgées
mais là c'est le fait différent c'est
utile à tout non tout le monde parce que
on peut être inquiet n'importe quel âge
donc il faut pouvoir se défendre regarde
mon bras est maintenant regarde mon bras
étendus mais quand même votre
enseignement il a un peu pour but de
nier l'existence de la vieillesse pour
vous la vieillesse est ce que ça existe
la vieillesse n'existe par monsieur
n'est le vieux qu'ils veulent est c'est
tout non non non il n'y a pas d'âge
décompensent sondages on se sent vieux
on est vieux parce qu'on se sent vieux
c'est ça comprenez que si vous dépendez
rendez vous pour défendre des jeunes
lieberman vous avez 85 ans et vous êtes
toujours jeune mais est-ce que vous
n'êtes pas une exception
on dit que je suis une exception mais je
ne devrait pas l'être
pourquoi parce que ce que je fais est
accessible à tout le monde tout
simplement
il ya des gens surtout parmi les
vieilles genre je n'ai connu et j'en
connais encore qui se complaisent
vraiment dans leur misère morale et
physique ne veulent pas en sortir à
chaque question que je leur pose
ils me disent ah oui mais vous comprenez
un mot nage alors c'est fini alors à
mona je ne peux plus rien faire et en ce
sens j'ai voulu être un exemple pour
montrer à tout le monde justement que
l'on peut le faire quand on veut on
trouvait la fin et en même temps jean
besse le travailleur je remonte en
souplesse
voilà est-ce que vous avez l'intention
de vous arrêter un jour
ah non à mon dernier sur seulement
obligatoirement
[Musique]